non j'accueille quelqu'un qui depuis
quinze ans additionne les tubes et puis
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que tout ça
n'était que des bonnes chansons et ça
finit par faire un répertoire de qualité
j'accueille marc lavoine
comment ça va jour je connais michel
bernier oui on s'est laissé michèle
bernier pardon sur renaud muselier
bonjour ind hardy et la la la la france
entière bonsoir j'ai dit bonsoir à la
bon alors marc lavoine thierry ardisson
ouais alors j'ai montré à la caméra
septième au zoom manga son septième
album et il s'appelle septième ciel à
malin il ya une chanson là dedans qu'on
entend tout seul la journée ça fait
drôlement bien
[Musique]
cette chanson when c'est très bien vous
connaissez cette chanson au nord et à
l'est bien triste façon il va la changer
et oui elle est vachement bien cette
chanson ça tombe bien la tournesol
caracol machin c'est geof qui me c'est
sympa mais qui valent à chanter c'est
pour ça qu'il a dit là il va la santé la
farine que j'ai parlé aux femmes aux
jeunes et qui peuvent ne pas vous parler
il un peu caracol tourner cagole cadors
c'est ce que c'est ma très bonne une
cagole non une cagole à marseille c'est
une [ __ ] chèque c'est la femme du
québec c'est là quand elle jouera à
marseille ça l'a fait qu'à gauche
voilà bon alors septième ciel septième
album tout style jamais composé six as
et nouveaux avant je ne faisais tout
temps les paroles sur vos albums mais
oublie qu'il était fort rare que vous
écriviez les musiques
oui ça oui parce que bon c'est fabrice
aboulker qui faisaient le jeu la partie
des musiques il les faisait mieux que
j'imaginais pouvoir les faire moi même
et puis là bas tournesol la musique
c'est vous par exemple pas mal les co
composé c'est un carillon à coeur je
mène les chansons et qui on est prêt à
mine avec quelqu'un j'ai besoin de jouer
sinon je balance à vallauris pas mon
travail sinon vous voyez quelqu'un qu'il
fort dans la musique déjà oui ça
valorise le travail donc ça nous engage
à continuer
[Musique]
voilà on est juste que tu colles et
voilà sérieux john et l'image tue mais
elle est en régie à vous je reste ouvert
c'est ma pizza la mission s'est apprécié
de faire des fondus enchaînés eux c'est
très haut niveau là en générant 62 à
longjumeau vous avez 37 ans vous avez
passé votre enfance à wissous ouais
votre père
il ya des marseillais qui bavardent là
bas ça m'étonne pas ce genre suis sûr
dès qu'il ya tu mets trois marseillais
ensemble c'était leur copain dit que tu
mets 3 mars effet garder il fait mater
j'aurais ils se marrent depuis moi
j'adore ces gens là depuis le début
rigole voilà ce formidable c'est pas
belle la vie
voilà ça me manque que ça alors votre
père marc lavoine ou et votre père était
fan de jazz il voulait être saxophoniste
mais malheureusement il s'est retrouvé
au tri postal à vaugirard parce qu'il
était tendance des listes voilà il était
très à gauche
très à gauche ou très à gauche
communistes syndicalistes y vend des
lumas dimanche
oui et collent des affiches et où ils
coller les affiches et enfin non
politiquement alors les lui seul à me
garer un moment il a dit qu'il avait un
peu marre parce que tu es militant et
tout ça et il a dit mon grand truc pour
échapper aux propos politisé
syndicalistes de mon père qui m'ont vite
écoeuré or voilà c'était partir non
écoeuré nom s'est pas départi tous les
week-ends à mobylette avec des copains
ils plantaient des tentes au premier
degré et il tourne et des spectacles en
plein air avec des super vite voilà donc
c'est vrai que quand même c'est maurice
est intéressant c'est à dire que vous
qu'elles étaient élevés donc par un père
de tout ultra gauche a pas d'ultra
gauche mais très à gauche tout moment le
discours vous ah non c'est pas lui c'est
pas son discours à lui c'est simplement
que moi j'aime pas trop les chapelles
j'ai été élevé de mon père était là
témoin je suis croyant je trouve que
chacun doit trouver sa sa nature sa
vraie raison de vivre de très rares
attaquants mama non je crois pas non non
parce que dans tous les milieux fois que
les gens vont enfin ceux qui aiment
leurs enfants et ceux qui les leur
laisse le choix d'aider chose est sûre
c'est un pas en arrière et serait bien
dans votre histoire c'est que finalement
on fait toujours pas souvent enfin on
accomplit un petit peu le destin que nos
parents auraient voulu avoir
on fait souvent ce que alors vous votre
père dont il est fan de jazz
saxophoniste il se retrouve au tri
postal à vogica évidemment ce n'était
pas le rêve de sa vie votre mère qui
veut être pianiste surtout dactylo et
vous finalement vous avez réussi un peu
pour d'une certaine façon oui mais quand
même et toujours une culpabilité là
dessus un peu ouais comme le communisme
est un échec il ya une sorte de d'un
coût de 2 d'avoir du succès quand on
vient d'un milieu communiste il sait ce
qu'on garde un petit truc de culpabilité
envers les autres on n'a pas j'ai pas
tellement vide
j'aime pas trop le brio tout ce qui se
voit tout ce qui se montre tout ce qui
est parce que je trouve que c'est une
agression un beau discours de tolérance
il ya une voix tellement bon je passe
sur à prétendre un jour une partie pour
de bon vous allez allions faire du hard
rock tout ça vous allez tout le monde
que les l'histoire à vous est coursier
et ensuite à l'olympia il est placer il
est où voir et évidemment c'était le
supplice de tantale pour lui parce que
si oui il voulait être star puis tout le
temps il a mené les gens dans les stars
mais quand il passe devant l'église
j'ai vu la lumière et donc un jour
patricia coquatrix donc vous présente
florence aboulker qui vous présente son
fils fabrice aboulker et vous commencez
à faire toutes ces chansons alors je
vais les faire écouter parce que moi je
trouve formidable tout à l'heure ils ne
sont pas tout âge dit simplement c'est
un choix personnel
levin avec toi et toi
dieu aurait volé elle a le regard qui
tue la collection première et j'aime ça
[Musique]
les arrange
non
j'adore la rue il avancé
c'est l'énervent qu'on se met ça mais
quand à j'écris ce texte là j'avais 17
ans si la chance parce ça c'est que le
conte c'est dire que dirait une bonne
fille qui l'a jamais fait laisse toi
aller ça quand on a 17 ans décrit un
truc comme ça quand on est à 37 génial
type de mondino avec catherine ringer
surtout catherine qui divise 1 2
sochaux ça c'est très vieux
[Musique]
bien ça que j'aime bien aussi non mais
alors justement attendait mais quand il
était petit l'était pas quand vous étiez
petit un grand nom mais d'accord valu à
m'appeler museau je vous fais comment
des doudous vous didier matiti et voilà
vous appelez gras double c'est vrai ma
plaie gras double parce qu'il était gros
peut-être voilages et le bleu rouge
[Rires]
jaune on n'arrive pas à y croire et on
le voit maintenant c'est du je fais je
travaille là dessus alors les prénoms
enfin les surnoms ont changé jusqu'au
dernier combat udc ravalec qui me l'a
donnée sur le tournage du cantique de la
racaille inca immeubles et marc couilles
marcouiller david veut dire que le film
s'y prêter vous étiez le mari de claire
nebout dans le même mais c'étaient des
échangistes qui allait au cap d'agde il
faut voir avoir vu ce film ça existe
[Rires]
c'était ça la fait makoun au départ dont
site c'est toute l'équipe reste humain
vient le chien surnom vous aviez là
c'est marco les grandes feuilles
oui c'est fait tu vois ses 54 mais elles
n'ont pas poussé les feuilles
il a commencé par regarder sérieusement
afin de vous trouver beau sérieusement
je ne me pose pas la question et puis je
m'en fous un peu
sinon on retrouve tous vachement beau je
suis un vieux et en régie on me dit
aussi tout le monde vous trouve très
beau et il ya du beau linge en rien là
il ya du france 2 et tu vois il ya de
l'allier de nuit là où il a rappelé aux
hommes et aux femmes
alors oui j'aime pas tellement je
préfère douaisis jean didier buzizi
le trouve plutôt dur vous avez déclaré à
mon physique je trouve plutôt dur genre
nazis couper au couteau
parce que comme je suis très
impressionné quand je vais à la
télévision de ça pour moi c'est une
institution parce que je la khl aime
beaucoup la télévision donc il ya des
endroits où j'ai tendance à me faire
mais sachez plus beaux d'une certaine
manière si on parle de caen je suis
décontracté quand je suis en confiance
pour ça que je reste
vous êtes bien là la chute ce que je
fais mais je connais bien la maison là
puis bon c'est vrai c'est mal sur un
plateau aussi les papilles à son arrivée
il est terrible 3 que la beauté ces
données se donner pleinement aux choses
et puis de faire corps avec la nature à
se faire à temps où elle est où ma
chanson moi on va se faire une petite
image rosa
penchez vous devez vous la main caresser
vous caressez vous tenez vous la main je
veux dire c'est que la beauce-etchemin
quelqu'un la beauté sans quelqu'un ça ne
sert à rien alors justement en 92 ou là
vous avez dit ouais
en parlant du couple le côté on ne fait
plus qu'un mois ça me gonfle en 93 il a
déclaré jamais je ne dirai une femme on
est ensemble pour la vie car j'en sais
rien alors est-ce que sarah poniatowski
vous a fait changer d'avis ou est ce que
quand même vous pensez toujours ça non
je pense pas ça du tout vous avez changé
d'avis je suis amoureux de la femme que
j'aime donc si tu veux ça ça reste un
problème c'est pas michel qui s'en
plaindra pas par tous les cas c'est
quelqu'un qui l'a le démon de midi moi
non vous non pas pour le moment tout va
bien mais moi la sexualité c'est parce
que je préfère vous allez faire des vous
allez faire des malheureuses la mort de
l'amour c'est quoi que vous préférez la
sexualité en dehors de l'amour ne
m'intéresse pas trop ce que je veux dire
donc jamais être chez quelqu'un de
peureux je suis pas du tout pourquoi pas
il préférerait la mention sexualité
casadesus arriver ça peut m'arriver
[Rires]
et c'est par communiqué est ce que ça
vous fait pas un choc vous fils de
militants communistes
d'épouser la dernière descendante des
rois de pologne est ce que c'est pas est
ce qu'au niveau du jeu pas quand vous
avez amené chez nous parce qu'un esprit
tout s'est bien passé j'ai viré le
écoute un sérieux c'est normal c'est que
ce choc des mondes je réponde non pas la
première fois mais quand ils sont allés
chez les bleus ce genre de questions me
déroute surtout venons de vous parce que
je sais que quelqu'un extrêmement
brillant mais je vous aime beaucoup et
c'est vrai que la question je sais
qu'elle vient pas de vous c'est une
question qui traîne que vous reprenez et
que vous me posez mais vous ne pensez
pas ça par exemple on sait pas qu'un mec
qui vient de mieux communiquer et aimer
quelqu'un du tout donc ça m'étonne
beaucoup encore la chanson je ne vois
pas épouser monseigneur gaillot non plus
voilà par exemple il est patient de
marché il ya simplement qu'on refuse
d'être surpris par la vie voilà dernière
question à marc lavoine ce mariage à
marrakech vous l'avez trouvé un peu
métier trop médiatisé non c'est vrai
thierry juteau décidé samassa ne va pas
at-il assené pagliaro c'est comme cette
question là c'est pas une idée avoue
c'est pas une idée à moi non c'est à
dire que si enfin ouf je peux pas non
plus ne pas assumer les choses c'est à
moi de c'est moi qui les fais donc je
devrais vous attaché de presse nous a
dit quitter avant les gens agissent sur
le dos autant réussi de les gérer quoi
ici tout lui c'est un enfer c'est que
oui mais met en revanche en revanche
j'aime beaucoup l'attachée de presse qui
travaillait pour moi à l'époque et je
n'aurais pas du tout je pense qu'il a
résonné d'une manière extrêmement
sincère
c'était à moi de penser que finalement
c'est vrai les attachés de presse vivent
plus avec la presse qu'avec les artistes
d'une certaine manière et j'aurais dû
avoir une analyse c'est pas très grave
comme quoi parfois faut savoir dire non
il faut savoir communiquer autour d'une
main que l'on a
il est très sympa dit
m
[Applaudissements]
ça va super et du beau monde ce soir
alors marc c'est vrai que pendant le
tournage du film de ravalec qui
s'appelle cantique de la racaille on
vous appelez marque ouille ça comment se
borne pas comme si c'était arrivé mais
tout le monde fini par l'appeler
marcouiller sur ce tournoi vous appelle
marcolino tu peux moi je meurs c'est à
lui marc aux seychelles
et quand il était plus jeune alors on
l'appelle marquant les grandes feuilles
mais la main non mais c'est quoi la tête
a grossi les oreilles en herbe plus
petit finalement aller quand même année
toujours des bonnes petites oreilles et
alors il ya un truc incroyable c'est
qu'à la même époque de marcolet des
grandes feuilles métier un peu du boul
vous appelez gras doubles il était mark
williams a reculé à vos boules jaunes
réunis sur donc bien alors aujourd'hui
ça va vous n'avez plus de complexes sur
votre physique
marc lavoine simplement vous dites mon
physique je le trouve plutôt dur genre
nazis couper au couteau alors ça quand
même
c'est terrible ça parce que vous êtes
bouillante ou non mais vous pensez vous
sembler une statue d'arnaud breaker non
non mais c'est parce que c'est un non
match 3 6 9 et 10 à la fois qu'il
m'avait vu jouer on a un tableau de ce
monsieur
ouais c'est le peintre du troisième
reich c'est le sculpteur des 3èmes à la
banque c'est sûr que ça ça fait plaisir
ça envoie son évasion il a mis en
confiance tout de suite hein c'est un
peu trop cultivé à ces facs en fait
lâché de presse ça fait plaisir sur
sembla à une sculpture dano breaker
alors votre père voulait jazzman il a
fini au tri postal à vaugirard on n'a
pas toujours ce qu'on veut dans la vie
et votre mère est pianiste est venu
dactylo fut pas loin de ces messages
avaient pensé c'est pas loin mais arrête
avec ses seins parce que
j'ai fait ça j'ai fait ça je me suis
jointe hier parce que deux des excuse
moi mais je comprends maintenant
en tous les cas on peut dire marc
lavoine que vous avez assouvi les
ambitions culturelles de vos parents
d'une certaine façon vous avez vous avez
fait vous ce que eux rêvé de faire une
certaine façon non c'est vrai alors vous
avez été élevé dans une culture
politique qui a complètement disparu
effectivement c'était le culte de
malcolm x le culte de la révolution des
oeillets au portugal
cohn bendit votre père vit toujours il
est monté sur le lion de belfort sas à
la salle fasciné c'est moi qui fais pas
signer le c'est vrai vous a été levée
dans ce mode là et quand vous étiez
petit vous croyez que tous les
communistes étaient chantier c'est vrai
j'aurais tout le monde était communiste
surtout près alors vous êtes chape et
tout ça en partant les week-ends en
mobylette avec des copains pour tourner
en super-8 des spectacles en plein air
donc voilà il y avait un truc aussi
c'est que vous vous êtes croyants et
votre père l'était pas oui mon laisser
un peu le choix
comment comment une croyance c'est ça
m'intéresse comment on peut être croyant
quand on vit dans un univers où dieu
n'existe pas et s'ils ont vu quand j'ai
pris conscience de la mort
ouais là je me suis dit
on est
voilà on est peu de chose vous êtes
croyante vous de génie quand on a rien
du tout ni papa ni maman plus rien
excepté un demi frère
je crois que c'est évident qu'on pense
que marie josèphe lamari dieu tout ça
c'est une famille j'ai abandonné la
prochaine sera du mont sainte vierge
jésus joseph c'est les parents puis j'ai
vite compris que huit sachets de la
tarte
alors bon vous finalement n'en voulait
d'un milieu comme on l'a dit communiste
avec ce que ça d'humaniste bien entendu
puisque sa terrible avec budapest 156 ou
prague etc et vous épousez la dernière
descendante des rois de pologne qu'est
ce qu'il a dit votre père n'a rien ça va
avec sarah non svanberg vous ai vue à
poil dur il ya longtemps
oui vous avez une photo de vacances et
c'est bien ma vie je pense que
convaincant s'en soit pointe sur une
plage tout le monde photo de face si
vous les avez ils les ont alors bon on
va terminer là dessus mais c'est assez
assez grave quand même ce que je vais
vous dire là en 97
oui dans le journal l'alsace vous avez
déclaré marc lavoine je suis un mauvais
coup d'algérie montrez moi ta main avec
jenny lcl a mieux c'est voir barry tu
lis dans les lignes de la main
bah oui un très bon et lorik loïc non tu
montes immo
avec les bandes innues aucun doute oui
les mauvais coups c'est comme nos
interviews dont l'interview parce qu'on
sait c'est toi qui l'a dit où des gens
ont dit que c'était ma mère c'est lui
qui l'avait dit bien alors votre
carrière au départ vous faites des
études d'imprimerie vous fait 1-1 s'est
ôté et d'imprimerie vous apprenez
l'imprimerie parce que d'abord vous
habitez avis où il ya des plaintes
imprimerie avis ou non oui cp2 après oui
ça pousse je vais tout le temps je vais
tout tenter un retour de cole mais je
l'aimé sous efficity en bleu mais c'est
bien d'être en bleu
bah oui c'est bien ouais c'est bien
c'est là où on voit justement fait vrai
que les gens font la différence
c'est dans des moments comme ça où on a
du cambouis ou là c'est vrai moi j'étais
en blanc moi j'étais un peintre en
bâtiment pour bragg et ben c'est pas
pareil
et bien alors bon vous êtes coursier
placer à l'olympia et là c'est
miraculeux un jour patricia coquatrix
vous présente florence aboulker qui vous
présente son fils fabrice aboulker et
puis voilà et puis c'est parti didier
mais il
histoire de faire des duos c'est parce
qu au théâtre quand on est au théâtre on
est toujours avec des partenaires c'est
vrai que quand on chante ça manque
fall elio surtout avec des femmes aussi
incroyable que vers l'élection c'est ça
non d'ailleurs
pour claire keim c'est en voyant clair
dans votre émission chartier que l on la
connait c'est clair on dînait ton temps
avec air vous avez déjà eu l'occasion au
nom et moi je cherchais quelqu'un pour
la chanson je ne veux qu'elle elle m'a
dit une vraie appelé clair c'est ici et
elle m'a dit elle a chanté chez ardisson
très très bien incroyable et donc du
coup ça s'est fait un peu grâce à vous
et à vous faire une interview sans
pleurs on ne bouge pas mal dans le
qinghai
[Musique]
attention marc lavoine est ce que dans
la vie vous êtes plus tôt
ou allô maman moment
allô maman bobo encore man ou halo tata
bobo à la table pour vous la vie c'est
ou alors c'est qu'on voit la vie en rose
nous vous êtes avec les filles je ne
sais pas où aller
[Musique]
ouais jojo extra
les filles vous les préférez comme ça
[Musique]
ou alors comme ça rires
un peu des deux y'a pas un oui une sorte
de menace bon je les préfère plutôt je
suis suis libertine au four est ce que
vous êtes
[Applaudissements]
ou alors
moi je sexy boy je peux rien vous cacher
vous savez tous deux mois et maintenant
ouais si marc lavoine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur
ça va très bien d'y être proféministes
vous parce que j'ai vu la façon dont
alonso vous a accueilli on s'aime
beaucoup de hors jeu ah c'est ça je suis
venu à la une pour ça vous savez à la
menthe bombers parti marc club rennes
c'est un mec qui sape avec les filles
qui est pas macho qui sait ça je peux
vous dire il est sexy grave c'est vrai
alors bon c'est un sexy boy
la voix non vous avez eu un petit peu
plus tôt dans la soirée sur le plateau
de la légende des voix une émission
voilà une émission animée par notre ami
n'est ce que je salue ici je mentirais
redit son ail et bien un t-shirt sur le
fil et je sais que tu as le live de la
carte mais demain quartier que je
conseille effectivement ces bigots qui
m'attirait que ça c'est génial a sailor
mille et un port on ne trouve pas encore
conserver alors donc vous étiez dans
cette émission ça s'est bien passé un
lien elle est bien maintenant
oui elle marche bien nous on la soutient
attention moi aussi j'aime beaucoup
naissent alors voilà dont marc lavoine
tourné en france un bientôt
et puis l'olympia du 21 au 25 janvier
c'est important ouais tout pour vous
parce que vous avez été ouvreur à
l'olympia on va maintenant faire quatre
jours à l'olympia en subir les tares
écoute c'est vraiment incroyable
j'ai toujours habité dans le quartier de
l'impôt c'était pratique la partie bien
loin comme je connais pas de voiture que
moi je j'ai mérité dans le jeu envoie
ses centrales à l'intérieur et puis
c'est vrai que c'est eux qui m'ont logé
nourri blanchi pendant trois ou quatre
ans accueillis avec ma troupe de théâtre
dans laquelle je bossais nous aurait
prêté la salle de billard la place à de
bien au dessus de l'indien ensuite c'est
eux qui m'ont envoyé aux éditions du
rideau rouge qui m'ont fait passer des
auditions et serge rousseau à l'époque
était le grand agent de deux verres de
depardieu qui est venu seul
auditionné à l'olympia et puis vont ils
m'ont présenté les producteurs avec
lesquels je suis toujours les
compositeurs comme fabrice aboulker ça
je leur dois beaucoup
si je vous dois le duo est claire keim
grâce à tout le monde en parle à
l'olympia je dois beaucoup
donc marc lavoine à l'olympia du 21 au
25 janvier
alors juste un mot comme ça vous
parrainez marque depuis le douzaine
d'années une association qui s'appelle
le papotin c'est le nom d'un journal
publié par de jeunes handicapés mentaux
à l'esprit nous en dire un mot
ben oui ça fait quinze ans que ces
jeunes écrivent
et interviews veut des artistes des
artistes d'art contemporain des
comédiens des philosophes et puis bon on
a fait donc une trentaine de numéros et
puis dernièrement c'est vrai que les
hommes politiques se sont intéressés de
près à ce projet parce que c'est une
manière différente de mélanger la
société avec ses exclus et on y perd
beaucoup on ne ne vivent pas avec les
handicapés avec les enfants vivaient
dans ces pays on vit encore très proche
et très ensemble donc c'est vrai que
bertrand delanoë
claude allègre bayrou jacques lang et
puis dernièrement évidemment jacques
chirac qui a accepté de faire une
interview de trois heures dans son
bureau avec douze jeunes aux autistes
ça ça a donné une dynamique une
dimension un petit peu différent donc il
s'agit maintenant de faire peut-être un
livre chez elle
[Applaudissements]
décidément ce marc lavoine n'a pas que
des beaux yeux bleus du bleu que le bleu
de ses yeux
je ne vois rien de mieux même nos bleu
des yeux
vous savez marc lavoine que les
téléspectateurs peuvent poser des
questions par mail aux invités de
l'émission alors vous c'est pas du
baratin j'ai reçu un mail et que c'était
bien
marc lavoine vous est désespérant de
gentillesse
oui pouvez-vous enfin dire du mal de
quelqu'un
marc fait un effort je sais que pour
vous c'est et riom est ce que je me mets
à votre place
vasco pourriez dire du mal de quelqu'un
vraiment une fois dans votre vie non je
trouve qu'on peut agir contre les gens
qu'on aime pas à dire voter descendre
dans la rue prendre position travaille
dans une association pour améliorer la
vie des gens qu'on aime contre ce qui ne
les regarde pas avec ses enfants
moi j'ai un enfant qui vit aux états
unis qui est métisse le 11 septembre a
été important pour les gens les blacks
aux états unis donc mon fils par exemple
leur donner une éducation pour ses 2es
les chansons aussi et l'attitude qu'on a
un peu partie du mal et du mal de
quelqu'un je vous jure le dire qu'elle
n'avait pas eu en dire du mal d'un
extrême droite ou dire du mal des nains
des antisémites des anti gay et je le
fais dans mes chansons
j'écris c'est ça la france pour s' agit
sur la prostitution pour ça avec ravalec
fait des films sur la guerre d'espagne
pour démonter les mécanismes fasciste je
m'inscris dans des avec des gens je
crois que c'est important comme les
restos du coeur ce pas une personne
c'est plusieurs personnes qui agissent
contre les mauvaises personnes je pense
que c'est sans espoir là je suis parti
dans ses retranchements j'ai fait une
connerie je suis parti dans un truc
genre d'accord je vois chez vous des
gens comme serait manuelle ou quand même
je vois l'action de personnes qui n'ont
jamais dit du mal des autres mais qui
ont nom justement c'est les gens qui
agit en reste et bien je trouve que
leurs actes sont plus éloquents que les
discours en discours et les silences en
disent non donc j'y arriverai pas j'y
arriverai pas là non
je n'arriverais pas non parce que ça
sert à pas grand-chose ne voulait pas
dire du mal j'ai franchement je me
battrai contre moi si je devais dire du
mal je suis quelqu'un de gentil c'est
vrai c'est pour ça que je demande sa
logique on passe un peu pour des
imbéciles à yves d abc l'heureux et non
on veut se battre on peut se battre
sérieusement contre des choses qui nous
révolte sans pour ce à dire du mal bon
bah je crois que 1
je crois que j'ai raté mon coup tu
l'invite je me barre non l'art est un
peu quand même deux minutes je me ferai
pas le voir mark
oui mais ça va bien alors vous avez été
élevé dans une culture politique
comparable à celle de stomy bugzy culte
de malcolm x révolution des oeillets au
portugal cohn bendit votre père vous
disais toujours c'est formidable cohn
bendit il est monté sur le lion de
belfort à denfert rochereau
alors tous les métiers c'était dans une
imprimerie avis où vous étiez en bleu de
travail alors dieu sait si vous
connaissez la banlieue il est un enfant
du communisme
chaque année votre père tenait un stand
à la fête de l'huma vous vendiez le le
muguet le 1er mai et même si depuis vous
avez épousé la dernière descendante des
rois de pologne danger toujours en
contact avec la réalité quoi c'est vrai
j'avais réunion cellule jusqu'au les
affiches pour le programme commun que
j'étais un enfant aussi j'avais 14 ans
j'avais la jungle et pif
j'ai utilisé du gaz et des crises bureau
j'avais la carte des jeunes communistes
ce qu'il m'en reste c'est si le désir
d'aimer les gens j'entends ce discours
aussi beaucoup dans dans des propos
d'homme sage n'est pas seulement un
homme politique je crois que ce qui est
important c'est d'aimer les gens et des
s'est développé autour de soi une
énergie comme ça de vivre ensemble je
crois que le problème de demain ce sera
à vivre ensemble il faut s'y attaquer
ouais fraterniser moi j'y crois moi oui
mais si les allemands ont été capables
de fraterniser avec des français en 1914
sur les tranchées pas pourquoi on
n'arriverait pas à fraterniser avec les
gens des banlieues aujourd'hui non mais
surtout qu'on y est on a affaire à des
français on est on est des français donc
il faut la glace il j'estime que disons
que les français issus des migrations
qui sont des frères et des soeurs et que
et on a un beau travail à faire ensemble
dans un joli paix il faut le réussir
ça ne paraît pas impossible comment ça
va parce à bien et toi c'est vrai que ça
très bien alors c'est quoi cette
histoire d'un incendie d'appartement la
non mais c'était avant les événements au
niveau 6 s'il fallait des banlieues
comme non mais c'est quoi cette histoire
a brûlé symbole eh ouais pourquoi mais
peut-être pas envie d'avoir un contrôle
non mais c'est fou comme on s'aperçoit
qu'on est possédé par les choses qu'on
possède une façon d a plu c'est un coach
ou la perte brûlures ont été attachées à
plein de trucs puis finalement il tu
restes tu es enfant et reste ta femme et
reste ton énergie et toute ton
expérience tu l'as en toi mon c'est un
peu angoissant quand tu trouves tu
retournes dans l'appartement où tu vois
la chambre de ta fille carbonisés et
c'est donc c'est vrai que j'ai beaucoup
de chance quand on va pas en faire un
plat parce que quand j'ai vu les
familles entières - boulevard vincent
auriol et son programme
irréparable l'a vraiment moi c'est la
gnognotte
mais c'était dû à quoi cette histoire de
cigarette c'est quoi - écoute je
rentrais de voyage on les voit là on
fait ma femme était vous fait la pub au
froid il enfin feu de camp la traîne
ma fille était à la maison avec sa
nounou ça s'est mis à brûler
alors y at il une incendie non mais le
problème des glandes surrénales aussi
c'est vrai mais tout est oui je suis
tombé un peu malade sa c'est toi c'est à
l'airé glandes surrénales
assez de ces la cortisone totalement
encore la surrénale quand elle s'arrête
tu lâches plus lentement que les gens
qu'on 92 ans dans la rue dumas est un
peu fatigué c'est une incidence sur
l'érection écoute à long terme tu veux
dire ou alors sur le moment là sur le
moment sur une montée crevé et donc
ouais je sais pas je voudrais pas entrer
non plus dans le détail c'est dû à quoi
ça les glandes surrénales les problèmes
des glandes surrénales c'est dû à quoi
le rapport aux rentes au jour parce que
12 de valeur étalon et thématiques
oui s'ils sont ni rognon car on va
batailler du groupe abba chez vous allez
et puis accident de ski aussi
non moi j'ai eu relation de moquette
c'est à dire tiré d'un conte où j'étais
dans un aéroport en asie j'allais je
partais avec mes enfants je me suis pété
la gueule dans la moquette devant tout
le monde à l'aéroport et ma jambe s'est
brisé
c'est un peu con c'est chez reed j'étais
obligée de le faire et là bas c'était
sympa mais ayant heureusement qu'à la
musique quand même non vous êtes
beaucoup de fans bah oui un petit peu
vous aimez bien vos femmes bah oui je
les aime beaucoup locaux ouais interview
fans 1 2
alors c'est des questions de fin mars et
ton vrai prénom
oui c'est un génie de t'appeler lavoine
comme le légume écoute un peu au départ
mais celle là est un peu d'astuce et les
quolibets d'enfants les manifestations à
bâle
mais je me suis fait et puis j'ai
demandé à changer de nom et pas mon
producteur m'a fait écouter c'est de
bien chanter déjà ouvertes aux non plus
tard pour s'y attachent
c'est vrai que tu vis avec une princesse
ouais t'es finale ouais en sont restées
fidèles
ouais non vraiment vraiment ça ils sont
cools des [ __ ] très ça fait quoi de
chanter avec les élèves de la star ac
pour la cinquième année
mais coup tu sais moi je chante pour les
gens qui sont en face du poste
elles sont deux devant je fais pas de
discrimination je suis pas quelqu'un qui
fait de la discrimination sur l'autre
sur l'audience et s'appelait commente
maman michou non ta maman elle a pas de
lunettes bleues meshoe tu as déjà été en
prison je me suis fait arrêter ton temps
mais parce qu'en banlieue au départ c
break comme le disait leases je sais
faire et exactement pour le même genre
de petits larcins
la pique et des litres de lait nous
c'était pas le dos rond j'ai maintenant
hâte entendu les cris mais où 2000
tu es plutôt thé ou café
je suis plutôt café il c'est vrai qu'on
fait de la meilleure musique quand on
prend de la drogue n'ont ni quand on en
prend 1,10 quand on ne comprend pas où
ni quand on est au malheureux je pense à
nous vient comme ça d'un coup on sait
pas pourquoi je pense que fo est assez
sérieux pour faire de la musique quand
même ça se fait assez le matin arrêtent
ils s'en foutent ils sont fort bien
quand les puissants si les couleurs très
sombres
elle n'a pas de couleur me fallait aussi
aller en bois c'est pour ça que tu aimes
quoi au lit dormir j'adore j'adore le
lit le garde chasse et les landes
surrénales
le chrtr et le lycée mont lieux préférés
je tiens avec boccoli thème quoi au lit
et j'aime le contact de la couette ouais
et j'aime les annales comme ça non parce
que j'aime beaucoup rêver j'aime les
rêves tes cheveux c'est des vrais way gt
ou hier soir hier soir je chantais je
dis pas qu à arras je suis votre voiture
je rentrais chez moi
ouais j'ai une vie tellement banal que
maintenant pour entraîneur ya un mec qui
mettait pas longtemps la musique
mais dites-moi l'aura du péage de paris
béthune 20 minutes c'est normal en même
temps c'était pour bernard tu es belle
époque du football au corps il est sympa
johnny très tabbee tout paris et pour
l'entrée de la turquie dans l'europe
écoute ouais qu'est-ce que s'il fait
pendant les vacances
les vacances c'est vrai pour moi c'est
donc c'est le moment où je peux rien
toute ma famille ont profité à non-stop
shell en afrique cette année et
j'ai vraiment passé beaucoup de temps
dans le chai avec les massaï et je
trouve que pour une petite gamine de 7
ans c'est important de voir d'aller
d'aller voir les cultures d'autres
d'autres monde un monde est magnifique
le couleurs de penser le berceau de
l'humanité s'est déjà mis un string
migrations de l'humanité
j'ai bien sûr une garantie ni un string
t'as déjà les astres et oui pour le film
de vincent ravalec portique de la
racaille c'est vrai qu'elle est très
bien et les choix tout nu ouais alors il
m'appelait c'est rigolo me disait marc
foutu le fassent sinon je ferais pas nu
un bon alors je te couple habite au
montage une dizaine
c'est même pas la peine d'y penser c'est
marrant que tu parles de ta vie depuis
la dernière question des fans s'est
taillé une grosse [ __ ] c'est con comme
question non franchement pas je peux
enfin centimètres raconte patrick
leur décès
one c'est sûr nouvel album
[Musique]